we rock stars and we question for you
you like Game of Thrones of course you
like to even Thrones everybody loves
game it sucks but you notice how we all
became incredibly okay with an
incestuous couple on TV just because the
writing so good we wanted to see just
how okay people are with real-life
insects so we posted an ad for a room in
a gorgeous apartment with an amazing
view and very cheap rank of course we
don't want to live there but what if
your roommates were the kind of brother
and sister there were a little too close
would you still want to live there eat
the Lannisters Jamie I love each other
very much
okay okay I'll agree come on save it for
the price we've got our cameras hidden
and we invited six lucky applicants to
take a tour of the place how are you
come on in this is the place beautiful
meet their roommates parameter word ah
no my sister stays here too with me and
see if they're a good thing this is Game
of Thrones in real life
you just call me Jamie uh good funny
story actually a goat took my hand how
do you feel about cats
I don't mind cat I love cats and love
lions and terrified a wolf shared
ravenous come on out this is my sister
Jessie hi come on out check out the view
yeah that's my sister you're doing a
completely inappropriate says meet our
guest Maleeva I'm a Scorpio we're going
on my tan shut up outside there you go
yeah oh there you go yeah you're gonna
be beer basted I didn't make y'all
sticking it huh yeah why finesse
right got it we have a very close family
- I am protective older brother inter
comes and you're like part guys the
Midwest should have paid attention when
they said winter is coming I do a little
training at this place called sink our
gym I have a seat here's paperwork just
a normal stub leads to take a look at
tell me something about your family my
mom's a teacher she teaches do a right
now Yeah right
why are you sister I'm very tense look
after a while we're always talking
my sister's here nearly all the time I
would like her to not be alone
we have a very close-knit family doing
what hmm come on all right uh I will be
right back
ah we always pay our debt
okay that is a lot of affection between
a brother and sister but nobody's left
yet is the place that desirable what if
they had to share the room with a less
friendly lannister
who are you
back there retiring
yeah oh my god
ty I don't care
we can change it we can make this okay
okay we thrown sex incest and family
drama out there they can't still be
interested in this department can oh
really
very interested agree to live here you'd
be living with the Lannisters you just
got pranked they have a girls in real
life
all right so we're people willing to
live with the Lannisters if they got to
live in a great apartment now that
doesn't mean we're all ok with incest
though for some people it might be a
selling point so we couldn't reveal the
prank to this guy we had to ask him to
leave because he seemed like he was too
into it and he still tried to come back
and then he sent us a bunch of like
not-safe-for-work emails begging to live
with the Lannisters hey don't hit on
that guy he just wants to party whoa
thanks for watching if you liked this
video go ahead and hit subscribe we
really like to see what happens going to
take a TV show or a movie and we bring
it into real life I want to you tell us
what in real life prank we should do
next this is Game of Thrones in real
life I reckon that's all